[Music]
Lyonne
are dwindling in number in wild areas
and there's not many more landscapes
left available for them to expand into
they persecuted wherever they go it
becomes important than to look after the
populations that you've got wine cereal
and it really gets into your blood it's
a melting pot of opportunity and
development in a conservation
perspective sometimes the camera self
which was formed in 2006 after the
goombah community received an land that
to their heads we met with some NGOs
white lands and they wanted to know how
a vision the community took a bold step
to save this land aside for conservation
rather than having a traditional
language nature conservation can also
happen for black community as well
they've been a community of firsts first
black runners first proclaimed area we
started to work and work and work it's
going to be our own camp reserve so that
we can generate more business
opportunity it's going to get this
reserve to be attractive as community
owners of the land there are the leaders
and community conservation environment
and they have really well managed lion
population they've got good genetic
diversity on their property
we're almost at full capacity actually a
little bit however we have the ability
to distribute the genetics from Pinder
elsewhere
right now we've got quite a task at hand
the way that worked in our favor are all
the checks have been blown out and you
can see it ok copy job got you all right
I'm going to come there now seize it and
have a look lovely we find the animal he
found some male that we're looking for
we know it plans to catch all these
lines tomorrow I think it's a good idea
to try and put this male into the bottom
and they need a square so we've just
pulled it getting the dart in then
losing sight of them once a dance in
that's the biggest issue as long as you
go to bait they will normally return to
the bait they moved from when we last
tenants are we pretty much have to try
to call them up from wherever they're
but okay there is right here some is it
definitely the one at the back there
it's important to know which animals
you're getting and what animals you're
giving so that you're not having two
bloodlines that are very closely linked
to breeding with each other again I
think it times you really thought this
wasn't going to work just before the way
they came in we were lucky enough to get
the first Mouse this is a six man we
would hope that we're going to be part
of the southern African lion meta
population management to ensure genetic
diversity is maintained on these small
pockets of disconnected reserves but
everything I've seen yeah I look I don't
know how much of coops gonna help in
this one day
[Music]
finally working after morning with with
some good way that we hoping to get
these two females now we need to rush so
we don't use them in a thick bush or the
grass where there are the moments are
exciting they still haven't really
formed pride structures as such so it's
the ideal age for us to take a male from
another pride and these two females
from a wardens perspective it's very
close to her we wanting to see lions in
the wild so now working with the Gumby
community here are some kinda we've been
able to do that looking good
they've traveled well and hopefully they
adapt to their new grandma
[Music]
yeah after a long week of work Lee
sitting inside the some kind of oma
we've got our three beautiful lines
coming back to the area after 100-odd
years rewilding the property is an apex
predator is going to create a real
natural system that's going to make the
reserve thrive they are all tolerating
into the wall which is a really good
sign for the bonding process I think
it's looking good so very here they're
variable open to telling my government a
passel of them is the last big page of
my dream
it's just paving the way for the future
of this reserve and this community and
the continued effort to contribute to
the biodiversity and conservation of
South Africa and Africa at lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]